oh yeah so I'm talking about some work
that we did recently uh just sort of
trying to optimize these recent
techniques based on randomized smoothing
to really kind of boost these numbers
this is joint work with a number of
excellent collaborators so here are
their smiling faces yes so this hottie
saman he's a resident MSR is Greg yang
researcher there on tongue
Ilya and said okay I guess there is some
obligatory slide about neural networks
but these in the room so it's okay okay
and then changes at the last second
we're good okay but you know there are
these neural networks that are they have
a virtual examples strip things and you
can get these things to misclassified
and we've really talked about them a lot
from an academic perspective um and it
really is interesting kind of
philosophical mathematical question why
they exist I also do want to point out
that there are very real-world
applications and issues because we're
using deep learning for increasingly
important tests so for instance here's a
really interesting one from the 10th and
keen security lab so this is like they
were using Tesla's self-driving system
and they were able to like the
put these dots on the road or something
and ten
the Tesla autopilot thinks that there's
like a fake lane and it tries to like
you know reverse into this Lane in
traffic so you know not only is it a
very you know academically interesting
issue it is it does have very real
security concerns in very variable
settings all right so let's define the
prom again so we've seen a number of
definitions already today but I want to
make a I want to make a slightly change
a slightly different perspective on
things just because it'll be convenient
for me future so right now I'm just
gonna give you the standard definition
so what is this so we have some
classifier it takes points in Rd to some
set of you know classes Y and we have
some perturbation set s which for
instance can be like some LP ball or
some set of small perturbations and the
idea is we say f is robust to
perturbations within this set at the
point X if f of X is equal to f of X
plus Delta for all Delta in this
for me will be slightly convenient to
slightly generalize this which is
instead of taking classifiers which you
can think of mapping every point into a
single class I want to consider soft
classifiers so a soft classifier this is
still pretty standard but slightly
different over you're doing PBSC it
takes every point in Rd and it signs to
it a probability for every class and
these probably sum to one so it takes it
to the set of probably the distributions
over in my classes why this boy okay
but you can do the same thing so I would
typically denote soft classifiers with
capital letters and I'll say that a soft
classifier is robust
if sort of the most likely outcome okay
according to the probabilities it's time
to X is the same as the most likely
outcome at X plus Delta okay for any set
for any Delta in my perturbation set
this talk I'll typically focus on this
perturbation set being the l2 ball I
don't I think as with the previous
speakers I don't want to get into this
very moral and philosophical issue of
what the right perturbation sets are I
will just say that perhaps you know it
might not be sufficient to consider such
LP balls I think people are converging
to this opinion but at least it seems
necessary that we should be resilient to
these sorts of perturbations
but this talk I'll focus not only just
like I know people both Yelp - I'll talk
a little bit about Ellen finiti
so a Zico discussed in his overview
there's sort of two broad approaches to
making no networks robust there are
these empirical defenses which I would
characterize as they work the best and
practice as and we don't know how to
attack them very well but typically they
offer no provable guarantees and I guess
so are the most famous and arguably the
most interesting of them is ever so
training and the variance theorem that
people been proposing and there's been a
lot of work recently because there's
been this sort of you know Ken mouse
game I guess as you go put it you put
out some defensive then Nicolas Carlini
breaks Italy except for except for some
noble accession I mean there's of course
this notable exception of a virtual
training seems to have at least for now
stood the test of time okay but to break
the cycle we introduce these certified
defenses which I would characterize as
they provably work you give you some
provable guarantees on your test points
but often they don't scale to large and
actually real-world neural networks or
they get worse numbers so there's these
for instance exact methods based on
mixed linear interpreter programming or
satisfiability modular fear uh theories
which are like very exactly actually
give you the exact guarantees but you
know these are like integer programs
they don't you know this is like np-hard
stuff you know intractable typically
although there's some work to try to
scale them up and as Eko talked a bit
about his convex relaxations which is
the part of the talk which wasn't his
talk and then there's also been this
very recently interesting line of work
on randomized smoothing which is
actually what I'm also going to focus on
in particular in this talk what we're
gonna be focusing on this can be
something I try to combine these nice
properties in particular we know that
these empirical defenses work well in
practice we know that these have proofs
can be somewhere like boost the provable
guarantees of these methods by you know
somehow attacking on these empirical
defenses and the answer I guess is we
can specifically I will focus on these
two things show how to use a drill
training done in a very carefully chosen
way somehow improve the performing
randomize smoothing fairly substantially
here's a brief outline of the talk so I
guess this is some unavoidable but I'll
have to do a little bit more background
I never so training and then I'll try to
get into our result and tell you how we
achieved these are the numbers that we
report here with these ideas of just
average so training person with
classifiers and there's some like
subtleties here that I want to really
get you interesting okay so background
now we're still training hopefully some
of you are at least somewhat familiar
this point but the idea is empirically
and there's some you know justification
for this based on these like Danskin
stands kinds of things standing on
average so examples
seems to make the network more robust at
least empirically although typically
this offers no provable guarantees so
the idea is this is a typical SGD style
update you know I have some model I have
F and a loss function l and afters
parametrized by parameters theta t so to
update my models with that robustness I
would just do the following STD step I
would say T plus I want to say the T -
some step size some the grading of the
loss at a randomly chosen training
okay but this is not robust and to make
this robust the idea that versio
training is instead of training on xt
you train on X hat T or X hat T is on
the adversarial perturbation of xt for
the current model and ideally XT with XT
hat would be the following it simply
would be the Arg max and so sort of the
the worst perturbation in my allowed
perturbation set so again I'm taking out
you here and by worse I mean it
maximizes the loss of my current model
so then I take this X hat T and then
plug it in here and ideas and this is a
point which we should be robust that but
we currently are not so by doing this
procedure we're sort of you know telling
the algorithm to XE be robust in
empirically this seems to work pretty
well
I get variants of this and also
techniques that I like added on this
team to get the state-of-the-art
okay but again these also do not
typically offer any real proof or
guarantees
and I guess there's a I should say I
forgot the reactor can't do even this
process it's Arg max is highly non
concave so in practice what we do is we
do a first order approximation to this
which is or variants thereof sweeping a
lot of things under the rug but one
commonly used thing is something called
PGD which is simply I want to you know
Arg max a lot so I just take steps
gradient steps in the direction of the
loss and then it's ensure I stay within
my perturbation set I project back every
other step and just repeat this process
like beauty and getting there other
bearings but this is the we're doing the
idea is that this is the first order
approximation of this ideal art max
okay
we're still training now let me talk
about randomized food thing again which
decode you describe but I want to
describe this in a slightly different
way although it's like more or less the
same operation
so given a soft classifier so one of
these things that assigns probabilities
to every point in X in Rd The Associated
smooth classifier you can write it in a
number of ways but you can think of it
just simply as a convolution of F with
the Gaussian with parameter Sigma
squared Sigma squared is alternatively
simply the expectation of F under many
drawers oh my gosh okay so when f is
actually a hard classifier or rather I
guess technically like the one hot
encoding of a hard classifier these two
definitions the this definition here and
the one that Zico gave coincide but this
is slightly more general that would be
useful for us
and this is sort of a similar cartoon to
what you could get this is from zico's
paper you know you take this I guess in
this case is a hard classifier so you
know blue is sort of the thing
classified as one class turquoise or
another purple so on and so forth and
then I take a point X and then the
Associated smooth classifier this gives
you a soft classifier which just
associated these probabilities it's
simply the probability that a Gaussian
drive from this point lands and each one
of these
okay and so I should say that gets as
Zico pointed out this is like a pretty
recent line of work it's very
interesting especially in the
perspective of randomized smoothing so
it started by look here at all there's
me at all and also good paper it sort of
the interesting thing that when turned
out is that you have this certifiable to
robustness if you use randomized
smoothing so this is the bound in his
paper the other papers again proved
other bands but this is I think the
tightest one lately so I'm just more or
less restating still what he said and
the slightly I guess more general
setting with still so it's in a multi
class setting but you can still think of
it as binaries well it's the same thing
but if F is a soft classifier and X is a
point in Rd what we do is we take the
most likely class of the smooth
classifier a we call PMA the probability
that the smooth classifier signs to this
class a and B is just a second like
least second most like a class P be the
probability of this move classifier
signs so PV and then the theorem and
their paper is that the smooth
classifiers were busted X for any l2
perturbation of size or less the same
thing okay so essentially if you have if
your smooth classifier is confident
about the prediction then you get some
l2 for some radius and again there's
these caveats which I'm going to try to
go through kind of quickly you know we
can't actually evaluate these
efficiently but these are nice easy
things to estimate with high probability
you can assemble them to extremely high
position with Monte Carlo sampling and
we're pretty confident that these
numbers are correct up to an air of
something like 0.1 percent and I think
most of the papers use kind of this
number it's a very small number anyway
so we should be confident that after
this very small fairly probability all
the things that we're saying are correct
again this is not like very probability
of anything but the internal randomness
oh yeah
then sampling for every data point is it
yes but that does not mean that there is
no there is nothing in the cassette you
have to take the Union bound you should
take a union bound over the test set but
like I would say yeah at the most you
know we should increase our air
probability but or like the fraction of
things which like the fraction of points
which we say are sort of 500 buy
something like this percent right and
also empirically like we very mild
perspective we'd like took this you know
the the sampling to be really really
large and we just observed no difference
and that consideration as well it
doesn't seem to make a difference
okay
so now let's talk about our ideas and
the idea is that as Zico pointed out I
think in this talk you can't just take a
vanilla Network and inspect that when
you smooth it you get a nice numbers for
anything because in particular you're
still doing this cache and smoothing
operation fundamental meaning you're
trying to classify with this smooth
classifier so the smooth classifier
needs to work well even get like good
clean accuracy otherwise you just kind
of can't expect to get anything some but
you need to train a network to exploit
the fact that in the end what we care
about is the underlying or the
associated smooth classifier not the
actual based model and in his paper you
know what they did was they they showed
that Gaussian de domination is already
quite effective at least empirically but
as I'll get you in a bit somehow it
seems morally not quite the right
objective to actually that we actually
want to optimize like it you know it
should it sort of does the right things
it encourages you to be good under
Gaussian perturbations and this kind of
stuff but when you actually kind of get
into the more concrete things of what's
going on I think you can maybe get a
better objective
okay and by using this bed reject even
getting like much better numbers and
that's what pretty much this sort of
does we provide somewhat more
sophisticated training techniques which
allow us to substantially boost a
certifiable accuracy okay so let me show
you some of the numbers now here's some
of the experimental results so these are
the paper these are the numbers that
were reported in azygos paper where at
least there's like re-creation of them
so they're like vetted these are good
numbers on both on CFR and imagenet and
these are certifiable numbers so the
every column is a different epsilon
radius and there's like this is like the
fraction of points which we can certify
using that nicely
nice point out that I believe this is a
bit of a hairy statement so I'm going to
like don't take this as word of truth
completely but my understanding is that
the best empirical accuracy for LT
perturbations on CFR 10 is this work by
Roni at all
which occurred in cvpr in 2019 there
might be better text now I'm not sure
but this is some reasonable benchmark
and essentially an epsilon is equal to
0.5
they got empirical accuracy so not
provable and caracal accuracy 67% and
and that's something equals one they got
roughly 40% okay so you can see these
numbers are like kind of close but
there's still some gap here and these
are also numbers for a minute
alright so with our techniques we're
able to boost this bolt on both imagenet
and CFR so just by using sort of our
vanilla ideas we can already improve
things by absolutely 14% numbers so far
it's something like six to seven percent
on the image net and then very
interestingly if you combine these
techniques with more sophisticated
things like pre-training or semi
supervision that like Ludwig's been
working on you can actually boost these
numbers even more and actually fairly
substantially as well so here I believe
the best numbers that we can get and
exactly I think these are quite
remarkable in particular if you look at
for instance epsilon zero five you get
65% and absolutely still the one we get
like 39% so we're off from like some
reasonable I I think perhaps the
state-of-the-art again this is a bit of
a murky business we're off from these
like reasonable numbers by two or three
percent so and you know it's I don't
think we've ever been in a state where
like the provable accuracies have been
this close to these empirical bounds
which typically do much better okay and
I also I mentioned I was mostly talking
about l2 I also want to mention L
infinity so here are some results from
this semi supervision paper which I
believe get the best day of the art for
L infinity certifiable and I can see on
C 410 so there's sort of two baselines
here typically so here is what they're
doing is they're taking L infinity
accuracy at perturbation level epsilon
is equal to 2 over 255 you know for the
famous capers I think they typically
like them the original papers they take
like eight over 255 but this is also a
reasonable benchmark especially for
certified defenses
and you know what the numbers that they
got were something like sixty three or
four percent certifiable accuracy at L
infinity to over 255 well we do well too
but you know there's if you make your LT
ball big enough it contains a
corresponding affinity ball so if you
just make the use the trivial embedding
of L 2 into L 1 and just like see you
what numbers we get at that radii for L
2 when you take the corresponding radius
for L 2 for L infinity of corresponding
to 2 over 255 we actually get a
certifiable bound of 68.2% so I believe
also just using naive L 2 techniques
we're able to improve upon the state of
the art fell infinity at least for small
radio just you know certainly if you
robust to perturbations there then
you're also robust it's kind of
surprising that you get like any
reasonable numbers here because you know
that there's like a huge booty
distortion in theory but I should say
that you know this is not gonna get this
does not as far as we can tell give you
state of the art for epsilon is like 8 /
255 which is like something one of the
other standard beam benchmarks it does
give you something like 25% ish and I
was quoted that like the state of art
certifiable something like 35 percent so
we're like not great not terrible
okay so I don't mean Ike to get these
numbers sorry so how do we actually
train for effective smoothing how do we
approve upon the training that was
proposed in like these uh in because
paper this Gaussian data augmentation we
have sort of two key insights first that
we should always be directly working
with this myth classify there's no
reason in some sense at least from a
moral point of view ignoring things like
optimization so not work directly with
the smooth classifier and it seems like
Gaussian data a mutation is doing
something like this but it is not and
I'll explain in a second the second
thing which is not really a super novel
idea but once you get the idea that you
should always be working with the smooth
classifier like just only ever with the
smooth classifier it makes sense that
you should just try to encourage this
move classifier to be as robust to
perturbations as possible certainly if
it is not robust and you can't certify
that it is not robust um so you should
just try to do whatever training method
that's going to make a smooth classifier
as robust as possible
this lease the natural idea of certainly
we should just ever surely train the
smooth classifier as still as we can
hey this is more or less what we do and
when you do this technique and this is
like I would get these nice numbers
okay so how do we work with this myth
classifier okay so a little bit notation
first let me let x1 through xn be the
sorry x1 y1 through x and y and be the
training set and let L be a loss
function typically just think of
cross-entropy loss for instance the
ocassion data augmentation is doing it
is minimizing the following loss it was
minimizing the sum over my data points
I really shouldn't think of the
expectation over the like training
distribution regime of the following the
expected loss of my function at a gas
perturbation because I'm training my
point on get I'm training my model gas
perturbations I want my model to work
well on points where I've got a
perturbation this is suitably what I
gosh and data invitation is doing is not
quite what we care about because what we
care about is simply the loss of this
move with the classifier so sort of the
objection that we pray about the loss of
jisub f of x i but you can write that in
this way alright so the sum is don't
really changing you think so let me just
like write the thing for a single
actually let me know it apparently okay
let me just write these out more
carefully but you can see that there's
there's a subtle distinction here which
is I mean it seems it's kind of silly
but this L we pull it outside but this
is a very like from a moral perspective
a big difference because the fault of
the former never talks about the smooth
classifier is just telling the Bayes
classifier to somehow be robust the
random Gaussian noise we don't at some
level care about that it might be a good
proxy for it but what we really care
about is that the smooth classifier
itself trains well so this is what we
should be doing we should always be
working directly with functions that
have the loss of the expected
yeah and this is like super important
for like getting the numbers that we get
and this will also come up in one other
place so as long as make sure that we do
this some of the natural like the other
ideas just kind of follow fairly
naturally so you know I want to not only
train this this move classifier but I
also want to like make it robust I want
to average daily train the smooth
classifier so how do I do this
well again so this is the original
sorry absol training for a base
classifier I find an average so
perturbation of my function f and this
is like my idealized perturbation
instead what I should be doing is now
I'm going to be doing an absurd
perturbation so I'm going to be taking
the loss of the smooth classifier here
and we'll be finding average our
perturbation of the smooth classifier
so far hopefully make sense and again we
can't do this exactly we have to somehow
approximate it using some first-order
objective so we're going to do some sort
of PDD kind of attack reduce well though
we also investigate the permanence of
another attack here like this recent CVR
paper this decoupled Russian in norm
again it's a some sort of descent method
or ascent method or descent method but
performance is similar so I'll just
focus mostly on
okay but this is more or less what we
want to do and again I want to emphasize
this point which is that this is the
perturbation that we're trying to find
we're trying to find an idealized
perturbation of the search trying to
find a perturbation of the smooth
classifier so this is the loss of the
smooth classify when I write it out when
I expand out like L of G sub F and we
call this smooth AB for serial objective
then poorly this is not the objective
which looks very similar and which you
know we got confused by at some point
and we tried again this thing were the
expectations on the outside anyway from
like a number of optimization point of
view like from that perspective this is
like much more natural but from the
perspective of AXI trying to find
average shell examples for the smooth
classifier this is definitely thing to
be doing feel like I'm saying this plot
but the hammer this home you know what
this is saying is find me an average for
example of the truest smooth classifier
find me a point such that the Gaussian
majority vote will be wrong at this
point this is saying find me an average
shell example of F that is itself robust
the Gaussian noise if I mean I'm
Michelle example for the Bayes
classifier search that when I perturb it
it is robust and this is we don't care
about this and you like it might be a
reasonable proxy to settle over for this
but we don't care about you really want
to directly optimize this even though
this like makes our optimization life a
bit worse
yeah so there is no direct and quick
formula you can write or the hard
classified on the left side no it's a
bit it's been messy XE so there there's
like things you can actually do which uh
if you can actually write down exact
reading forms for this I'm not going to
talk about this too much in the talk but
for whatever reason they don't work very
well and so much more naive estimators
work better
yeah so for you just opt people finding
that for example you need to evaluate
this yes so this is actually one of the
things that is a limitation of the
method which is that you know adversary
training is already really slow we can
only do like ten iterations maybe and
that's already gonna blow train time by
a factor of ten and when you do this is
gonna make it all so bad
so there's like so I'll show you some of
the hyper parameters and like in a bit
but I think we try to mow something like
relatively small constant like ten or so
that's like just the limitation although
I should say that we only use like ten
samples for train time but when we
evaluate you still use like thousand ten
thousand or whatever so this is gonna
give you some weird heuristic for
training but in the end it does give you
better certifiable numbers if I copy
the Gaussian noise of smoothing Alex was
it we should not be doing symmetrically
because there are the directions of
shape so from a heuristic perspective
definitely it seems reasonable to try to
do this but if you want to get like
certifiable numbers at the end as far as
we know unless you have some prior about
like the shape of the distribution you
know the best we can do is just take at
least rail to just take the standard
Gaussian and use like the name of
Pearson style results on that I mean it
is reasonable actually and there's
something we were interested in trying
out there just like during aqua zation
instead of using like a standard normal
gash and trying to adapt that to the
shape of the distribution somehow but
yeah for instance but we're not sure how
to do that particular it's like even if
you're robust to perturbations in a
different Gaussian it's not clearer than
you'll certified well with you know a
nice view of Gaussian because these are
also kind of already different
objectives but it's still interesting
yeah we're not entirely sure how to
optimize this this is just sort of a
first attempt
yeah so looks like this is kind of a
sweet tip but so far we tell you Mike
yes good yes so this is this is a good
observation which is that when you
there's another perspective on this
which is that somehow this is sort of
approximating some sort of like softmax
or like getting rid of some sort of
softmax and it is actually very
interesting to try to vary this
temperature parameters associated with
softmax although in practice forever
whatever reason when you do it the one
but you can try like the it is
interesting to like try for instance
like the though
whichever one corresponds to softmax
approaching to max these kinds of things
um we wanted to try this at some point I
forget XE if we did exactly exactly
if you if you take sort of like free
parameter or free time sure parameter
that's going to this you actually take
the something that spoke to the hard
classifier and that's like at the very
end what you like cared about originally
yes at least empirically does not seem
to work as well
at least in our well I mean maybe we you
know maybe you can't do something we
haven't we don't claim that we've done
everything you know I think it's
interesting to try to try the things cuz
in the end it is very natural to try to
do the actual hard classifier here
particularly you can even take gradients
of it
oh yeah to drive this point home that
like you know this objective yields
stronger tax and this objective is just
a plot so sort of the the black line is
the performance of this attack so lower
accuracy means a stronger attack and as
you can kind of see I mean it's kind of
squished down unfortunately but as you
do the smooth adversarial objective with
enough samples like something like even
eight or so you're gonna like beat this
attack especially like in smaller LT
radius G and typically at least in I
wonder though you know we believe about
ever so trainings at the stronger they
attack the more robust the resulting in
smaller which makes sense training Atari
and so this difference actually seems to
result in like a big difference in
numbers is the yeah I'll show I'll show
that curve in a second it's like sort of
tight at points but not almost a yeah
why are they different for M equals one
why aren't the thing good question
I Bilbo it does unless you let me get
better
another question okay
all right so yeah we want to always
again work with this smooth adversarial
objective so then the main question for
all these things is how do we evaluate
gradients so we need to value gradients
of the smooth classifier again we're
gonna focus on the cross entropy loss
let me do so so we need to both need be
able to take gradients with respect to X
and theta so we need to take gradients
with respect to X to actually find
average of perturbations and agreeance
with respect to theta to actually do the
update steps but the problems for the
two are more or less the same so I'm
just going to focus on getting a
gradient with respect to X and you can
write it out now these in the infinite
sample regime where I take many samples
of Delta as this kind of formula and
there's actually a number of nice things
you can do with this formulas that we
don't up end up using like you know this
is a you know a gradient like gradient
of a log is you can just do that and you
know this is just the gradient of F
convolve a Gaussian so you can take the
grading of F involve get I shouldn't in
fact even in the gradient free way in
terms of F right you can the derivative
of F convolve anything is inside the
derivative of F convolve that or f'q
involved the gradient of that and the
gradient of action is like very nice is
like missing called static effects you
can do like nice closed form formulas
for this that you can then approximate
where you have Monte Carlo sampling get
like nice unbiased looking estimators
for it but we tried these things and I
mean I can show you the numbers but they
don't work
we conjecture this is because of the
resulting estimator so you get have
extremely high variance and we are in
this extremely limited regime where we
can only take a very small number of
samples and that's probably why they
don't work but we're actually that's it
because you're see twice I recently
received a small Sigma squared yes the
issues that dimension is gonna be large
right dimensions is D so some out yeah
so when you when you take the sort of
the Stein's lemma based estimator this
corresponds to like sampling bunch of
directions and kind of down weighting
the ones in which they're bad based on F
and somehow this seems have too much
variance to actually be a reliable
estimator unless you take too many
examples so despite the fact that
there's like cool things that we tried
falling very naive estimator which
doesn't have any frankly nice properties
as far as I can tell
work the best empirically which is
approximately this in turn expectation
with a something okay
yeah
it has you know one redeeming factor it
is in fact asymptotically optimal under
some model assumptions like it will it
will converge the true gradient but it
is that's pretty much it is not unbiased
at least from a theoretical perspective
again there are these you know much more
sophisticated things that we could have
tried for the gradient it just don't
work hey but that's pretty much it so
the full algorithm essentially goes like
this
we're XY in the data set what we do is
we find an adversarial example for the
smooth objective so we take X add to be
X plus noise and then we iterate this
process with projections
and then we just train on except with
respect to these this atmosphere
perturbation and we chain not F but G
this smooth classifier and again for
whatever reason the best thing to do is
take the
yes but rather than thinking as to
whether you have an estimator and
whether that is tomato it's accurate why
not just think that this is the best
degrading and therefore maybe there is a
difference in training due to great
universities but like what is this a
stochastic gradient of it's not big but
it's a gradient of a log of an
expectation having moments it doesn't
even have this it's a gradient or
something else in fact you know you can
say something it's not it's not like I'm
like maybe say it's too bad for instance
in some sense if I normalize away the
norm it's you can couple this with the
an unbiased estimate of the direction
because the log pulls away and then you
do get something which is linear on the
top but you know the directions that you
get are completely arbitrary this is a
fresh stem a fresh veget every picture
this step always the same like I goes
for my well good I forget exactly I
believe it is the same but it didn't
make a huge difference did you try to
estimate the variance
that's a good question I don't think we
tried very yeah just to make sure at
this point none of your science right
like now it's an inspired some method
inspired so the training never had a
theorem but in the end we're gonna get
some classifier where this we're what
other guarantees that it is actually the
bust well then what you can do you
evaluate you know the you evaluate the
smooth classifier you get these at a
point X and you evaluate the PA and PB
and you see how that you can certify at
that point so as if you were going to
every example this is so this is on
training and after we get some model
what we're gonna do is we're gonna go to
the test set and then perform this
procedure and see what fraction we can
certify that is like our estimate of
like how for like a fraction of the
points from the true distribution we can
survive so from that point of view it's
very exactly just the method to try to
get a bit like something that makes
Yukos team stronger
we have a number of parameters which I'm
I'm not sure I want to get into but this
is somebody asked this at some point for
instance the number of you noise samples
we use during training was very small I
was like 8 or so this is a clear
limitation of our method but it seemed
like it's very like doing this on like
c4 and imagenet I already took like a
lot of MSR GPUs and we have like number
GPS so it would be very interesting to
like do more but it's it's already
pretty hard to like do this kind of
stuff so here are some plots
corresponding some of the numbers so the
left plot is sort of the upper envelope
plot so the x-axis is the ultra radius
of the loggia and the train was one two
four eight that was the number of
samples in this
and yeah when you use to estimate the
Gaussian noise yeah because it's just
you know the more a Gaussian noise that
he used sort of the longer it takes to
Train like about a linear factor and
like average so training already takes
so it's like definitely doing like
different if I like choose a new sample
X Y or they'll be different yeah yeah
yeah sometimes I'm amongst the ten steps
of PGD we do these are all tiny numbers
okay so let's plot is the upper envelope
so there's like for every epsilon what
is the model that gets the best or if I
bow or empirical accuracy so red line is
the numbers from the CMU paper so the
solid lines are always the certifiable
accuracies you can see you know and the
dotted lines are the like the empirical
activities that we got by trying to get
I guess are strong as attacks against
them and so you know we do I would say I
mean particularly if they're interesting
we actually do better than the empirical
performance certifiably and this also
answer some other question I think which
is that you know there's still some gap
between the upper envelopes between the
certifiable empirical accuracy that we
get although it is somewhat smaller
which is nice
hey the middle plot is a similar up
envelope plot so it's what we do is we
take the best take the best model for a
fixed Sigma so Sigma was the hyper
parameter which control like the
Gaussian variance that we had and for
every Sigma and for every epsilon we
found the best model applied our
survival and Pyrrhic all accuracies
compared to just to make sure that you
know we're not like doing this just
because we're doing like a huge sweep
over hyper parameters because we do do a
much more dramatic sweep over high
parameters and the same your paper does
we also just tried some like we found
some representative models or less
randomly selected we're like how do you
went into some files and there's like a
huge pile of files click on one in these
numbers and again for even for fixed
models to each one of these lines now
represents a single fixed model we still
do better and also you're every results
for image net which are similar and
these jumps are artifacts of the fact
that we couldn't run as many things on
those aren't real but that's just
because everything that takes forever to
rent okay so as I mentioned before we
can also boost these methods even
further by combining this technique with
some other recent ideas so there's this
paper by Hendrix at all we showed that
pre-training on some sort of down scaled
image net and then like fine-tuning this
model on seapower 10 improves the robust
accuracy on super 10 so if you do the
same thing so you pre-trained a smooth
classifier on image net that's robust
using this technique and then like
fine-tune it empirically try that and it
turns out it boost a I could see a lot
similarly there is a result by yeah
Carmen no it's sure that you can use
like unlabeled data to improve empirical
robust accuracy on see part 10 so we
kind of use the same technique that my
supervision
but again for smooth models and again I
combining your techniques with them you
obtain like even higher certifiable
accuracies as we showed in the original
table I'll show it again in a second
yeah but I guess somehow yeah that's
true yeah you guys yeah
there's a very interesting point I want
to make I don't really get why this is
happening
there's some weird things with the
numbers our Quinn's identities or
something I'm not sure what it is
essentially both pre training and
supervision kind of or semi supervision
seems to help her numbers dramatically
you can see like 82 these like much
better than before and they're very
similar actually like somehow they're
like off by two percent and then
combining them there's barely anything
and oftentimes doesn't even help I don't
really understand why that's happening
but it's interesting yeah yeah so if you
assume that the smooth base model helps
why didn't we just do for fun
propagation and make kids like smooth
sorry what kind of operations so like
for example like the ones like people or
like yeah the previous Mike on I mean
it's it's a reasonable idea I'm not sure
it quite makes sense because you're like
combining out to an Ellen Finity kinds
of things right but we didn't try it for
sure it's also like this is ready like
take forever to write on quite possible
Avenue carefully to the pen right that's
a very critical I mean you may sacrifice
yeah so we I mean we perform some the
blasian studies and some of the plots
are actually somewhere I can just
probably like maybe classroom but
choosing em at least like a slightly
larger constant didn't seem to change
things too much very interesting there's
a lot of unexplained phenomena here I
mean we get like these numbers which to
my understanding are like you know state
of the art very nice but there's a lot
of stuff that we don't understand I
thought like why these are happening
which are a very interesting question
okay that's pretty much all I want to
say in summary I hope that you take away
from this talk as well as eCos talk that
randomized smoothing is an extremely
powerful technique training these
cruelly robust models and by combining
episode training with this randomized
smoothing you can connect substantially
boost the provable accuracy that you can
get there's still a lot to be explored
so there's a like a number of open
questions well the first thing is that
while it seems like these things help a
lot for the small epsilon regime when
you're at phones like relatively large
like epsilon is equal to 4 so the boost
is much smaller and also very
interesting leap retraining and semi
summation just don't help at all there
at all it's very weird it helps so much
when epsilon is relatively small but
just nothing again I think a question
that a lot of people I just didn't is
like can you do some other norms like L
Finity with some other smoothing
mechanism if it's possible or not and of
course a big question for a lot of
people is like can we go beyond LP like
can we do smoothing for some non
Euclidean norm like move a distance or
varsity inducing to those guys
yeah that's pretty much it um I'm told
that if you scan these you will get
links to the papers but I don't have a
QR scanner so but also if you know you
can do probably search on the internet
and you'll find it
[Applause]
did you take a look like the six guys
you've ever seen the gap is between
crane and testa and is it big or small I
don't think we tried that yeah
[Applause]
thank you very much for having me
so my group hasn't do a lot of empirical
work and decide to try to use deep
learning for science and the great